في فقره وقفه مع الحدث نتوقف عند التحفظ
الالماني ارسانا الدبابات الثقيله
اليوبارد الى كاف اذن اسباب هذا التحفظ
وتداعياته مع زميل وسيم الدالي اهلا بك
وسيما
الموقف برلين من ارسل هذه الدبابات
الثقيله والهجوميه الى اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
الحاجه الاوكرانيه للدبابات الهجوميه خاصه
التي تطالب بها الايام الاخيره همم هي
تقريبا نحو 300 دبابه وواحدها ليوبارد
الموجوده بهذا العدد على القاره الاوروبيه
اذا المانيا لا تريد ان تكون مساهمه في
الصفوف الاماميه الهجوميه الاوكرانيه
بنسبه 100% التسليح وحتى هذا الموقف
لمسناه في الايام الاخيره عندما قالت
هولندا انها تريد التسليمه همم هذه
الدبابات اليوبارد الالمانيه الصنع غير ان
همم الموقف الالماني كان في البادئ الامر
انها لن ترسل هذه الدبابات طالما الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لن تقوم بخطوه ممثله مع
دول حليفه اي اي انها تعطي الضوء الاخضر
لهذه الدول ل اا تصدير دبابات من صنع
امريكي هذا من جهه من جهه اخرى هناك مواقف
داخليه وضغوطات داخليه على المستشار
الالماني
وهو ينتمي الى الحزب الديمقراطي
الاجتماعيه وهذا الحزب في عقيدته
التاريخيه انه لا يساهم في الحرب وفي
الجهود العسكريه وانه يساهم في نشر وتعزيز
السلام
ما بدا معه الحزب الديمقراطي الاجتماعي
ولكنه تغير الى الواقعيه السياسيه ومن
ابرز الوجوه الموجوده من هذا الحزب هو
وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه انا لينابير بوك
ولذلك شاهدنا بعض المواقف المتباينه بين
وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه يوم الاحد عندما
في فرنسا قال انه سيتشاور معه همم الدول
الصديقه والحليفه في اشاره الى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في الخطاب مع ايمانويل
في السربون ولكن في نفس الوقت وزيره
الخارجيه تصرح وتقول ان المانيا لن تمنع
تصدير همم الدبابات الالمانيه يوم امس في
المجلس همم الاتحاد الاوروبي همم كان
الموقف همم وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه هي
الاصطفاف وراء المستشاريه المانيه اي انها
ستتوحد المواقف ولكن جوزيف بوريال في
المؤتمر الصحفي قال استنادا الى التصريح
لوزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه ان المانيا لن
تمنع التصدير الدبابات الالمانيه طبعا هذا
ربما يبنى على اعتبارات ايديولوجيه للحزب
الديمقراطي الاجتماعيه ولكن ما يعاب على
المستشار الالماني انه لا هو ولاء كبيره
لعدد من الشخصيات النافذه في الحزب
الديمقراطي الاجتماعيه
مثال على ذلك عندما قدمت وزيره الدفاع
الالمانيه السابقه
يوم الثالث من يناير لم يعلم الحكومه ولا
وزير واحد بل اعلم قيادات اربع قيادات من
الحزب همم من بينهم رئيس كتله كتله همم
الحزب الديمقراطي الاجتماعي في البرلمان
همم الالماني وهذا ما يؤكد ان هناك طبعا
هناك بعض من يقول ان القدس هذه الكتله لها
ينتمي الى اليسار وهو له تقارب كبير مع
فلاديمير بوتين وهذا الشق يراسه رئيس هذه
الكتله وهو الذي قال ان حزبنا لا يمكن ان
يكون حزب حرب وبالتالي ربما هذه
الانقسامات على الصعيد السياسي والتي ربما
يدفع ضريبتها اوليف في الوقت الحالي
باعتبار ان الموقف الموقف تسليم النبات
الدبابات لم يتبلور بعد يتركوا المانيا في
نوع من العزله في هذا الملف ملف تسليم
الدبابات
همم ما تبعت هذا ربما هذا التحفظ الالماني
هناك من يعتبر تاخرا في تسليم هذه
الدبابات الثقيله والهجوميه الى كاف
ماتبعات هذه همم هذا تحفظ على المستويات
الاقليمي والدول من ابرز التابعات هو
الاستفاده الروسيه من هذا التاخر
سيسود له الاعتقاد والاقتناع بان الاتحاد
الاوروبي وخاصه المانيا لن تستطيع ولن
تتمكن من تسليم الاسلحه النوعيه وكذلك
بالكميه وبالنوعيه اللازمه
الاوكرانيين وساخذوا هذا الامر بعين
الاعتبار في الاستراتيجيه العسكريه في
الايام المقبله خاصه على مستوى همم الشرق
الاوكراني وتحديدها في منطقه الدباس حيث
تخوض القوه الروسيه معركه كبيره مع القوه
الاوكرانيه هناك ايضا همم ستفقد المانيا
المصداقيتها مع الشركائها خاصه في ملتقى
الشرقيه الدول الاوروبا الشرقيه
والوسطى ونعني بذلك بولندا على سبيل
المثال وربما ايضا دول البلطيق التي
كالتفيا وليتوانيا التي تساهم بشكل كبير
في هذه الحرب دول مثلت فيها مثلا تساهم ب
1% من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي لبلادها في
مساعدتي اوكرانيا العسكريه وبالتالي ربما
سيكون نوع من الانشقاق وفقدان الثقه لدوله
تعتبر المحرك الاساسي للاتحاد الاوروبي
وربما نفهم لماذا بولندا اقترحت تشكيل
تحالف صغير في الاول خالص قد نستغني عن
المانيا في هذا التحالف الدول التي ستصدر
الدبابات لاوكرانيا باعتبار انها تعتبر ان
مساله امن اوكرانيا من امنها باعتبار
قربها الجغرافي هناك ايضا همم ربما قد
تفقد المانيا مصداقيتها مع دول اخرى كبيره
في همم حلف شمال الاطلسيون العمل بذلك
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه همم
هذه القراءه التحليليه شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا